[Musique]
les deux militants de greenpeace ont
quitté aujourd'hui volontairement le
porte avions clemenceau toujours bloqués
au large du canal de suez l'egypte exige
en effet de la france des documents
prouvant que le bâtiment répond bien aux
normes de respect de l'environnement
greenpeace assure elle que l'egypte
subit les pressions françaises pour
permettre aux clemenceau d'arriver en
inde afin d'y être désamianté nathalie
perez
c'était hier matin dans les eaux
internationales au large de l'egypte
deux militants de greenpeace prennent
d'assaut le clemenceau qu'il juge
hautement toxiques après cette opération
spectaculaire le gouvernement égyptien
interdit aux porte-avions d'entrer dans
le canal de suez il exige que la france
présente des documents prouvant que le
clemenceau ne transporte pas plus de 50
tonnes d'amiante ce qu'affirme le
ministère français de la défense selon
greenpeace on est bien loin du compte
la société qui a des amiantés le
clemenceau à toulon le considère qu'il
doit encore 500 à 1000 tonnes d'amiante
à bord du clemenceau quand on voit les
conditions de travail dans les champs
type d'émission en inde où les gens
démantèle les na'vi à coups de marteau
de chalumeau et en arrachant des
morceaux de métal oui il ya une très
forte exposition à l'amiante
même son de cloche ici à brest ces
hommes ont travaillé sur les peler
manceaux ils sont aujourd'hui regroupés
dans une association de victimes de
l'amiante ils ont tous été intoxiqués on
trouve anormal qu'on exporte de
l'amiante dans un pays étranger du fait
que en envoyant le crémant sous là bas
sachant qu'il n'a pas été totalement d
amiante et donc nous sommes en prenant
en train de faire de l'exportation
d'amiante ce soir l'egypte n'a toujours
pas autorisé le clemenceau à rentrer
dans le canal de suez pour poursuivre sa
route vers l'inde c'est ici dans ce
chantier à ciel ouvert que le
porte-avions français va sans doute
finir ses jours démantelé et désamianté
par c l'indien qui travaillent à mains
nues et sans la moindre protection
l'inde ne possède aucune réglementation
dans ce domaine et encore moins le
savoir-faire dans une activité à haut
risque
[Musique]